So far, we've built up a healthy
collection of NP-complete problems.
But given that there are thousands
of known NP-complete problems,
we've only scratched the surface.
In fact, we haven't even come close
to Karp's mark of 21 problems from
his 1972 paper.
If you want to go on and extend the set
of problems that you can prove to be
NP-complete, you might consider reducing
subset sum to the knapsack problem.
Where one has a fixed capacity for
carrying stuff, and
wants to pack the largest value
of subset items that will fit.
Another classic problem is that
of the traveling salesman.
He has a list of cities that he wants to
visit, and he wants to know the order
that will minimize the distance
that he has to travel.
One can prove that this
problem is NP-complete
by first reducing vertex cover to the
Hamiltonian Cycle problem, which asks if
there's a cycle in the graph that
visits each vertex exactly once.
And then Hamiltonian Cycle
to traveling salesman.
Another classic problem is 3D matching.
2D matching can be
thought of as the problem
of making as many compatible couples
as possible from a set of people.
3D matching extends
this problem further.
By matching them with a home that they
would enjoy living in together, and
of course, there are many others.
The point of this lesson, however, is
not so that you can produce the needed
chain of reductions for
every problem known to be NP-complete.
Rather it is to give you a sense for
what these arguments look like, and
how you might go about
making such an argument for
a problem that is of
particular interest to you.
The reductions we've given as
examples are a fine start.
But if you want to go further in
understanding how to use complexity to
understand real-world problems, take
a look at the classic text by Garey and
Johnson on Computers and Intractability.
Even though it's from the same decade
as the original Cook-Levin result, and
Karp's list of 21 NP-complete problems,
it's still one of the best.
As Lance says, a good computer scientist
shouldn't leave home without it.
Now that you have a better
understanding of the nature and
scope of the P versus NP question, we'll
return to high-level in the next lesson.
The next question's like,
what would happen if P were equal to NP?
What good might we be able to do?
And in a world where P is not equal to
NP, what are the hopes for coping with
the NP-completeness of problems
that we would really like to solve?